he wants to to show he's still a great
chess player aha and we see the game is
uh starting now essipenko against
nepogniacci we have to mention one more
thing and the thing else because there
is something called a fighting chess
index and jan pomnyacci after yesterday
he was on top of that table correct so
there are different
algorithms that goes into the research
of the fighting chess index and among
those things are the size decisive games
and nepali actually hasn't played a
single draw so that helps and also
it looks into whether or not you have
short draws for example with the white
pieces
um and overall you play longer games etc
so it just goes to show that he's there
to fight and to to win win games and
we're going to pay a lot of attention to
the fighting chess in index throughout
the whole season correct correct so at
the end of the season we'll uh
hand out some prizes to the most
fighting players on the tour so that's
exciting wow and it's looking good
friana pomnyacci the game against
esefenko just started david will we see
some fighting chess in this game i'm
pretty sure we will see some fighting
chess um as you have getting mentioned
these guys a lot of respect between each
other but they are rivals first and
foremost and uh it's the italian game
it's still early days but we've seen
things open up it's not the traditional
uh way that we see players handle this
type of position we've seen a pawn
exchange in the center already dark
square bishops have left the board now
knight's leaving the board as well lots
of exchanges but still a lot of life
left in the position the pawn structure
isn't balanced and it's also going to be
very difficult for black's king to
castle if you look at white's light
squad bishop it cuts across uh towards
the king side and yeah this one
i have a feeling that we'll see some
fireworks later on what do you think
you're getting uh
i uh i disagree disagree
uh it looks like both players uh still
in book it was italian a4a5 recently
analyzed with the
exchange of the bishops on e3 more or
less popular direction if you follow
some live live book things
and uh
yeah i think uh very soon the bishops
going to be traded and it will be
more or less simple position which is in
objectively in favor of uh andrei
yesipienko
uh because he likes to play more
technical stuff and uh
yeah
okay so
yeah so we will see uh possibly some
more exchanges and the game fizzle out
slightly but uh esepenco now has to
accept that the queens are going to come
off the board uh jan deciding okay if
the black king can't castle then maybe
the safest safest approach is to
exchange the queens what do you think is
he going to take that queen now is he
going to just leave it
maybe just maintain the tension for a
while yeah i believe he would deliver
the knight
on c5 uh he was a bit faster than me to
do it
so and
potentially black already leaves the
king in the center so i i predict that
at some point black will change on c3
then we'll keep the pawn on b6 and the
bishops are going to be traded on e6
white will keep the phone on g4 i just i
just say we'll have to show you some of
the stuff
like uh
kind of predictions so it it it will be
it will be a lot of exchanges black
already centralized the king for the end
okay but yeah everything going uh
is going different compared to what i
said yeah so for example okay white has
put the bishop in the center okay let's
just show what's happened instead of
castling why it's put the bishop in the
center we have seen a trade here so a
bit of an odd pawn structure for white
but a lot of central control and very
flexible to push forward later and uh
black
maybe wants to exchange these bishops
but whoops sorry black wants to exchange
these bishops but not right now because
this would allow bishop takes knight
type of move and black's pawn structure
would be compromised therefore he does
drop his knight back first next move
he's gonna go for your idea try try and
trade these bishops and uh yeah but it's
it's pretty interesting uh because white
gonna play rook b1 potentially
threatening to take on b7 and uh king
gonna be in the center
uh still
okay he's trying to put his king in the
center first
now now you can guess who is technical
player who is not
yeah we wanted to go on the attack maybe
but
essepenko just nicely centralizing this
king look how safe it is uh behind all
of its pawns and kings in the center as
we saw from yan as well are perfectly
safe they're ready for the end game and
now a big decision actually he's pushed
his pawn forward hoping for maybe an
exchange here because suddenly white
gets a very strong pawn in the center of
the board which can be supported and
it's a weird weird pawn structure but
actually white's pawn structure here is
superior because he has more open lines
for his rooks so yesterday we talked
about doubled pawns being troubled pawns
here they're pretty strong and they're
very mobile as well doubled pawns if
they if you can't push them maybe if
they become static they can be a
weakness but here the pawns will start
pushing forward yeah with an advantage
so i don't think we'll see jan rush
necessarily but whatever
for a second i was really worried that
the bishop on d5 gonna be trapped let's
say bishop f5 to and then threatening c6
uh however there's a there are several
squares on e4 or f3 he will simply play
knight c5 like uh concentrating
uh the pieces in the center and
attacking b cell actually it turns
pleasant for white no yeah do you think
so
i completely agree i would choose white
here every time um partly it's because
if you compare the knights as well white
tonight is perfectly centralized black's
knight on the edge of the board white's
rooks are connected already access to
open lines
somehow i've maybe it's just my chess
education but i love these types of
double bonds when i was young just
because it gives you some dynamic play
even in the end game and uh okay jan
choosing to answer not by trading
bishops but by pushing his pawn forward
and now this knight is probably going to
jump to the square you mentioned
yeah unfortunately not because uh the
game turns really concrete knight c5
losing the pawn maybe because of the
king's run yeah i missed this one the
king would move forward and actually a
double attack so very sneaky from uh
yonder punishing here
yeah this would be a bit of a bit of a
blunder here because this pawn notice
how it's defended by black's passive
knight so maybe the knight has to go
back in another direction for example
stepping back this way and the game
would go on white's bishop can trade
itself off at some point but it also can
step back lots of tension just don't put
the knight on city please david because
in case of in case of c6 there are no
squares for this knight potentially
but the c6 is a big strategic concession
you're getting true i would just drop
back and i have a huge advantage now
look at this pawn
i don't know i would put it back here
every time uh okay i don't know uh
just
different uh different understanding of
several factors between grandmasters so
before we even we are ground masters we
play different chess yes
which way would you go back then this
way yeah i think g3 i think g3 yeah
then i could then i could argue i'll put
the pawn on this square and then your
knight is dominated and maybe you have
to come around back where i wanted to go
through but i was hoping that knight on
g3 will will put some extra pressure in
case of
e4 and gaining some some tempest yeah
but you are right you're right okay
let's go back to the players right now
really tense position okay ah i was
gonna say we should have a bet is he
gonna go back my way with the knight
your way with the knight he chooses a
third option a different square and
wow um this is why esopence you
mentioned regarded as a great strategic
player he brought his knight to one side
and that forced black to step back with
a bishop didn't want to initiate a trade
on white's terms and now pushing forward
with the pawn gaining even more space
okay really interesting move um
and now rook lifts we expect them in
middle games but not necessarily once
the queens are off the board black's
rook now on the sixth rank trying to
swing across
and
interesting move i'm not necessarily
sure that the black rook has anywhere
great to go later but
potentially pawn on g2 is hanging so yes
pengo has to decide what to do with the
knight
um maybe he yeah he he wanna attack the
pawn on e5 yeah um i think he's found a
better circuit than both of us suggested
yeah and and and much faster you know
this is about the type of position it
really fits yes pencil so he can make
plenty of moves by hand here and he's
out of the most uh dangerous side of
jan's chest
when jan is rolling on uh on the espanko
because andre doesn't like to to defend
kind of tricky positions so at the same
time he he he's pressing i i i feel he's
pressing and i i also feel that black
rooks are uncoordinated
and uh it's not easy to play
now oscar checked the head-to-head stats
between these two players being both of
them russian and i think he only found
one classical game between them so are
these two not sort of in the same like
training group in in russia at all they
don't sort of play that much together
uh i they're both national team members
and uh russian uh team have uh has the
training camps time to time but you you
you never know who are the or from the
players uh following the camps coming to
the camps it's from camp to camp
different number of players because we
have like 100 grand masters there
yeah and uh 2700 rating is not a
guarantee being russian team member so i
i believe they they know each other and
uh of course they play time to time but
we never know how many games it was so
yeah and official games very few and
look at that the bar likes it for
azepenko right now yeah um so jan
bringing his bishop back to where it
came from a couple of moves ago he's
really trying to insist on this bishop
exchange
but uh
i don't think uh esopenko necessarily
wants to capture that bishop maybe he
would back it up by a pawn that's risky
because there's some chance of white
bishop being trapped in the center of
the board but
if he can get away with it yeah possibly
he wants to go for that i like that
maximalist approach right
because uh you know whilst the bishops
are staring off against each other the
light square bishop is relatively safe
and i agree i think the knight sitting
there on f3 is on a wonderful circuit
eyeing up the unsupported pawn on e5 and
uh well he supported it with the pawn
but not the way i was thinking i was
actually thinking that would be the sea
pawn but okay it was a central pawn
maybe this is stronger yeah i was trying
to weigh up the pros and cons of both
moves and
i couldn't find a downside to this one
um yeah white bishop also will never get
trapped anymore because it does have an
escape route if the black bishop moves
um so maybe this pawn makes sense he's
also trying to fix black it is double
fred as well because you are not only
threatening to grab the pawn on e5 but
you threaten to change the bishops and
grab on f5 uh leaving there as a later
pawn on the e5 so by uh e4 he's
attacking both pawns in the center and
at the same time opening the e file for
the rook and uh kind of pointing out
that there is no consolidation between
the black species yeah very very clever
move and if we do see an exchange here
suddenly these white pawns become
monsters right and they can be supported
actually there's two sets of doubled
pawns here but
more importantly black's pawns are weak
and this would just be fantastic i think
for white
so i'm struggling to find a move here i
must admit as you mentioned you have any
like how do you defend both of these
pawns at the same time without making
the concession without playing a move
you don't really want to play with
bishop takes bishop
yeah see it yeah
yeah maybe
king goes to f6 but at the same time uh
it doesn't help basically because you
can trade the
bishops on e6 or you can slowly develop
the rook on f1 like potentially
threatening to open the file still like
king's move
is under all the discovered potentially
discovered threats and it's not
improving the position of other pieces
and this is why it is so nice to be a
spectator you feel none of the stress
and the emotion and talking about
spectators i do have to share with you
some selfies
they're great fun and uh mr dodgy uh
showed us a a selfie which is how he
enjoys every game of the champions chess
tour look at him he's outside landscape
mode check excellent air quality in the
ice cold absolutely and then obi-man
it say it's kicking off in glasgow
king's paw to e4
nice move look at that
cute little animals there it's a cute
puppy and a little highland uh cow and
then finally journey to fm says just
turning wait was that a cow it was a cow
it was a little it was
there was a cow playing chess inside it
was a soft toy
that's a first for me oh yeah and it was
a highland cow so it's like a lot of
hair oh that's a very british thing
right
wow yeah that is that's the first for me
i don't know about you guys if you've
seen cows play chess inside before
my dreams
very nice
usually there are a lot of tweets with
uh dogs with some other animals even
cats play chess but cows cows well yeah
enjoy enjoy the sights i've i'm glad
that ob man what actually managed to
shock us all here in the studio yeah and
uh also not forgetting journey to fm he
says just turning four and already a
huge magnus fan so we love receiving
your selfies and remember you can tweet
us your questions or anything and your
pictures in landscape mode are using the
hashtag chess champs and the crazier the
animal the better yes now we have a
small kind of cow highland cow
what else can you bring to the table
okay
accepted
meanwhile a couple of moves white
bringing the rook across just trying to
maybe open up a file for it and that
caused the pony actually to lock down
the center and advance the pawn so black
has lost a lot of flexibility but black
does have a poor majority
long term on this right side of the
board so
um something to hope for long term
foreign
trying to get his pawns rolling in the
center
and uh okay the bishops have come off
i'm slightly surprised that he rushed
with that uh bishop exchange i thought
maybe at least white could just bring
the bishop back and um allow the trade
to happen on his terms but but i i
believe he simply sees the d4 move yeah
but maybe there is a
kind of trick for uh for ian yeah
yeah
yeah there is the pin on d file and the
pawn on c5 is hanging so maybe maybe
this is the the trichyan hopes to
survive with otherwise the rook on a6 is
fully outplayed
this work is terrible right now and uh
yeah as you mentioned i don't think you
want to allow white time to just
build this great horn center supported
by the king later on these pawns will
just roll down the board and steamroller
black later on so in the previous
position look here maybe but then knight
takes pawn what's happening here
knight takes i guess is your
justification due to this pin and okay
yan has just traded off the pawns in the
center um this position would have been
complicated black has some ideas of
maybe some night forks hitting the king
hitting the rook but jan did not go for
this instead he did trade and okay he's
trying to improve his rook by exchanging
some pawns
and uh this one it's smart it's really
smart because white can't
avoid any exchanges on b6 and the b file
gonna be opened and finally the awful
look on x6 is uh back to play yeah it's
back to life and it will try to enter
the position so
is there a way for andre to
allow this porn trade but on his own
terms
it's not completely clear to me
i don't think he really wants to take
here yet because even after a rook trade
black at least is getting a bit active
so very very tense the same game if all
the rooks disappear white
well you could make an argument that
white is doing well but then again these
pawns long term are going to start
marching down the board still chances
for both sides it's pretty imbalanced
despite it being an end game now could
you try to kind of lock out the black
rook by just supporting the pawn on c5
with a rook
um which rook do you want to use your
anchor this one you pick the one
okay just for i'll give it a take i'll
use this right which wasn't doing
anything obviously after this porn trade
though white's pawn structure has been
compromised slightly maybe this is a
weakness long term
as you mentioned this rook is still not
great but it just takes a couple of
moves to relocate to this square maybe
to the d file as well
interesting definitely and it will be on
asap's mind but in case we compare to
the position several moves ago it's a
way improvement improved for for black
yeah and look at esopenko on the camera
he knows it's improved for black he's
not as happy as he was earlier not as
relaxed for sure
these pawns about to be eliminated and
black about to get active so let's go
back to the players
how will essepengo try and keep the
pressure i still slightly prefer wise
position i'm not sure exactly
how to explain why but it's maybe it's
just the pawn center it looks visually
appealing and
obviously maybe some extra weakness on
c6
controlling all the squares around
but anyway yeah he would trade and
change one pair of rooks then
potentially he would organize the
postpone on defile so rukuni one is
nicely placed and perhaps he's
calculating king c3 and king run two
to d5 i'm wrong again but uh it's it's
happening when you're playing graphic
chess yeah yeah really interesting move
actually by s pencil not an obvious one
as you mentioned i was instinctively i
would want to activate the white king
just it's an end game and cover some
squares that the black rooks want to use
but white now has brought his rook
across reminding black that there is an
isolated pawn on that c file and now
yeah
just unfortunately we don't see how to
attack this pawn on c6 we want to push
g5 g4 so the blacks play is really easy
at the moment and uh also the time
management uh slightly turns in black's
favor uh however uh
white yes white played rook c1 white is
pressing on c6 pawn but there is no
other move there there is nothing next
so i i would claim rook siwa unless sb
inaccuracy but uh well see yup we will
see um so at least for the next two or
three moves it's going to be quite
straightforward for yan to play and also
i've just noticed the cloud times he's
still got 13 minutes that's impressive
clock handling at this point in the game
i would be down to one or two minutes
and
i would be panicking trying to keep
control of the position but uh yeah both
players handling the clock very well jan
is known right to be maybe one of the
speediest players in the world yeah when
he's in the flow he's uh yeah a joy to
behold but um yeah maybe he's just
adopting the level on iranian strategy
as well which paid off so well just
playing instantly and putting the
putting the opponents under pressure
in more ways than one yeah but from from
opposite perspective it's not very
difficult for andrei to play this
position with eight minutes a clock it's
it's pretty a lot he simply needs to
decide what what is the plan what he
gonna do if let's say some jumps forward
works like 95 or he wants simply to
control uh the side by playing h3 a
little bit stopping the pawn and
changing potential weakness so uh he he
needs to spend one two minutes to
uh to create the plan and then to follow
this plan i believe like plenty of moves
would uh would come pretty fast
afterwards
but uh every move does have its
consequences and yeah you know it looks
great to
step the king forward one square but you
know suddenly there's checks on the
board or maybe the route can come down
to the second row
just at the right time
yep so plenty of options here for
yandere pognishi
i do like this move by esipenko i just
want to get that king as active as
possible if the rooks come off that's
going to be very useful but as you
mentioned you like it's becoming quite
concrete and uh what do we think what
would be first instinct for that yeah
the first instinct of course is to push
g4 but it doesn't work since it's like a
double fork a double fret after 95 for
for for both sides yeah hitting this
pawn and just to mention the other
threat while hitting the spawn as well
but also the more deadly one jumping to
this square with a check
for example if you protect this pawn
that's a [ __ ] what do you think about
the knights and game in case i would try
to trade the rooks by rook b3
if i give you the check clearly offering
to play rook city back otherwise there
is no sense of king d3 move
and rook takes c3 king takes c3
yeah who is faster which side is faster
white or black or black g4
than 95 steel yeah yeah still a problem
but maybe you just don't rush with g4
maybe you can just push your h-bone and
advance as a team
now maybe i mean there's still so much
to calculate here you can still jump
forward with the white knight hitting
this pawn
uh for example if the pawn marches
forward now there's still a check
there's still a double attack hitting
this king hitting the pawn there's so
much to work out nighttime games are
tricky
um i mean they're so hard to master and
right now this is what's going on in
yandere's mind does he want to check and
maybe allow a trade of rooks
i mean you have to allow the trade of
rooks pretty much if you if white does
block in this fashion because this pawn
is still under fire as well so it's not
completely clear i would be very tempted
to just push this pawn it just looks
like a useful move but then you do have
to answer the question what will be
happening if white starts pushing now in
the center and creating a past pawn of
his own
or also knight e5 anyway because there
is the fork on d7 we should never forget
about
still same idea hitting this point but
also more importantly this check so yeah
right now maybe this is actually a bit
of a threat and it's not clear how black
can deal with this
it would it does look very very slow to
step back with the king it just looks
like that's inviting white to start
pushing forward
and uh yeah key moment for yan and he's
thinking at this critical moment he's
using his time wisely it feels like yeah
and uh yeah i must admit i don't okay so
the complications have been initiated he
pushes forward with his pawn and now the
big question is wow the white knight
will jump into the middle of the board
and we're going to see this ending this
night ending and so how is this going to
work out it's incredibly complicated
look at the bar it's just they can't
decide really yeah i don't think we can
decide this is so hard to evaluate white
now is most likely well actually much
pretty much definitely just going to
block this check and we'll see the rooks
get exchanged and maybe white will win
upon this guy attack this guy attacked
but at the same time but maybe simply
king g5 and the king's run if you uh
take the pawn on c6 it's f3 and pass
pawn uh having the sport for the king on
f4
[Music]
so for example if there's a trade if
white's king tries to come across to the
rescue then the black king might step in
as well
and
these two look impressive but it's hard
to push them
actually it's very surprising to see
andre
so
excited i would say he's changing the
position every second and going more and
more down
in time so
you know
changing the position physically as well
right yeah just being very emotive and i
don't really know what he's thinking now
what are the other options you have to
block with the rook if you step forward
with the king there's a nasty check here
and all of your pawns drop off and
yeah you can't really step back because
this pawn is hanging as well in the
center to black's knight but don't we
miss kind of trick from the outside
after the rook straight on c3 maybe
there is c5 okay some intermediate move
using the hanging knight or nf and you
have uh nitro yeah uh i i move my king
okay which way this way e7 i believe
yeah
and
yeah and simply pawn in game perhaps
it's yeah perhaps it's lost yeah with f3
because white king goes to
uh to control f1 square yeah but in case
i'm not playing f3 at once
how do you advance the pawns let's say i
play king e6
or i roll the h pawn first yeah
it feels like maybe
this is the trick i felt that there is a
trick look at this move that's just
happened on the board let's backtrack to
the game position yeah we both missed
this we all missed this um now black
gave a nasty check with the knight
hitting the king and
the king had to move because after pawn
takes night we would have seen a rook
trade and black now is for sure winning
this king and 49 game the black king
much more active than white's king and
these pawns are going to win the day so
um yeah wow what a move
by januponishi he gave a check white had
to move the king out of the way but
after a trade here knight takes pawn and
suddenly jan is the one as black who's
pawn up temporarily and probably doing
quite well this is why now we realize we
understand why essepenko reacted he went
back in his chair head in his hands it
was all about this check knight to c5
hitting the white king and putting a
knight on a square it looks like it can
be taken twice but actually neither
capture was possible but it's not game
over still because i believe uh
andre has to regroup his thoughts first
of all his mind to to play more more
safe and to to play for a draw at the
moment to get king closer to the king's
height king d3 king e2 and then anyway
whatever black does even having the
check on c5
the same trick again returning the
knight he will grab both pawns on that
side so andre gonna grab the pawn on c6
on on a5 like after a knight c5 check
slowly going k2
and then yeah maybe you can still hold
the draw with white eliminate some pawns
in the process but now there's
definitely calculation to be done
he needs to be super accurate and it
feels like white is on the defensive
playing for the draw so yeah where to go
with this king as you mentioned this one
is the most forcing it's the one you
calculate first
but
still some work to be done and yan will
be trying to
maybe take advantage of the
psychological blow of his earlier check
to try and win this game let's see
whether white can hold it sorry i'm just
laughing at the the kind of whole thing
if he puts his king on the most natural
square the trick that he fell for he
didn't see the first time it's going to
happen again and maybe it's even going
to surprise him once more and
i don't know the lines looked very very
shaky there because
you know
there's past pawns all over the board
and when that's the kind of situation
it's all about just calculation yeah
actually we are getting very exciting
games today for uh for the broadcast
both games having the past pawn on the
both flanks
are those usually so are you saying
those are usually the more exciting
games when the past pawns are on the
flanks yeah of course when you have you
have to calculate a lot like every move
matters who is faster which side is
faster so depends on the promotion you
have to get closer and closer and to
predict all the moves and not to miss
such tricks as we did when you guys play
worse players than yourself basically
much lower rated players than yourself
is this a strategy you would do like
play on the flags
sometimes yeah sometimes i mean past
pawns are just harder to stop on the
flanks and and when it comes to a race
it's who's better at calculation simply
so
um oh there is the famous chinese book
by sunzi
the art of war one of the most famous
books ever where he compares
the war actually to the chess game
and one of the rules he says
that if you are attacking on the flank
you your opponent or you have to use the
center for counter-attack if you you're
playing in a center try to regroup and
go from both sides then
so i think every chess player has to
read that book by suzy
yeah it's it's enlightening but it's
confusing at the same time right
those types of rules trying to follow
them meanwhile talking of porn races
white has got a pawn back now but look
at those three black pawns
racing down the board together
i would be terrified here i must admit
the white king is it quick enough to get
back in time now
but uh i mean i don't know because
there's there's the big pawn break that
i'm seeing is that you pick up the f
pawn and move that one forward
and then once you know once white starts
capturing then it's the the pawn
alongside it that starts moving maybe
gives itself up so it's the corner pawn
at the end that can't be caught yeah
look at this these three pawns running
down the wood and your idea your anchors
i guess this one yeah obviously at this
time calculation it might be just giving
away my pawns if it's captured then this
pawn marches forward and this if this is
captured then this pawn marches forward
and this one is it gonna become a queen
it might well become a queen because i
was hoping to stop it with my knight to
try and give a check and stop it on this
square but now black gives a check
exactly and
then this pawn matches forward and this
is destined to become a queen that is
really really sneaky and in this
situation we have to mention the timing
so andrei is getting very long on time
and a lot of forks a lot of checks he
has to calculate because uh i believe
just by intuition his king is not in
time to stop all the black spawns yeah
this king's too far away
and uh he's going to be looking at lines
exactly like the one we were just uh
that ivanka mentioned there the king
dropping back and then he has to worry
about all of these pawn pushers he has
to calculate the more he has to
calculate knight checks instead he goes
for something else he brings his knight
back trying to race it back to the game
but jan now just improves the black king
guarding this pawn maybe now is the
moment before it's too late to start
running back with the white king
just what else it's very difficult to
see a move here other than trying to run
back with the king now honestly i'm
extremely surprised with the bar it's
showing white's advantage slight
advantage when black is rolling and
pawns are more advanced there is no pawn
advantage for the white side king is
more active so extremely surprised maybe
there there are again some hidden tricks
but from the human wise especially uh
humans perspective especially when you
have two minutes on the clock you are
extremely scared here that the the pawn
will simply cross your so you think the
bar should be further
all the way
opposites yeah
you think it should be on under side
significantly on the black side on the
black side yeah yeah okay now we get it
yeah or more yeah it should be i think
yeah it's surprising all the way yeah it
should be either very far in black's
favor or just in the middle with a drop
nothing in between really but uh
yeah maybe it's the evaluation bar just
showing that with best play white can
hold it but black still has the
advantage for now and okay white trying
to push a pawn that's very risky because
now black is simply going to go and pick
up some of
these thank you
it listens to you
yeah and one general rule is that you
don't really want to touch pawns on the
side you're weaker in general but
especially night end games he's actually
with this uh porn trade he's given black
a pass pawn for free so and not just
that but white's remaining pawn on this
side is gonna drop off black's gonna
have two pawns racing nice and
notoriously bad at stopping the flank
pawns as well the corner pawns they can
only stop it from one side so
it's yeah it's uphill struggle now it
looks winning for black yeah and i don't
like the place where uh it's a penco's
but his king
because it just means when the white
knight tries to step back the black
knight can come out of its cur over its
corner and would give a check to the
white king yeah quite possibly
also if white's knight steps back i
think the black king can
enter the action i think there's time
yep and yeah black keeps all the pawns
protected white can
uh well maybe andre was trying to
calculate racing his central pawn
forward white does have that one pass
pawn his own trump card but but black
snide yeah black snide is fast enough so
i believe he would play king e2 try to
hold the knight on f3 with potential
race of the d-pawn
but uh yeah knight g5 happening anyway
yeah
knight returns to control the past pawn
of white and then h and f will create a
lot of troubles yeah two forms are
better than one and black has two plus
forms white only has one yeah any knight
exchange as well as long as black's king
is in time to stop white central pawn
that would uh
just sort the game in black's favor and
look at jan his body language yeah arms
crossed he's just waiting for his
opponent to resign even though i think
esopenko should try and fight on i don't
really see how to be honest but
um yeah there are still chances there
aren't that many pawns remaining so if
white can somehow eliminate all the
black pawns even in return for his
knight that would be a draw but it's a
far-fetched dream at this point but it's
also very surprising that andre is
thinking because there is basically the
one move on board yeah you have to
retreat the king to protect your knight
what else to do
well an important result for anish giri
winning against hans niemann after
losing the previous game and he needs to
win games because he is currently
outside top a to qualifies for knockout
but obviously
many rounds still to go and an important
win for a new share so let's see if he's
starting a winning streak now and the
moves are coming out yeah the moves are
coming and not the moves that we
expected of white's king stepping back
instead white gave a check and he's
trying to run with his own pawn but it
feels very very slow it feels like
white's pawn will easily be stopped by
black's knight black's knight can even
just step back now and then the two
black pawns together are going to start
rolling
yeah there there is a pleasant choice
for black i i believe for both moves
advancing f pawn first to f2 or just
returning the knight to g5 and followed
by h pawn the most dangerous pawn in all
a knight and games
uh simply gives gives the win
yeah and this would actually be
devastating for esopenko in the first
game today he lost to artemiev another
russian player he could be about to lose
to another compatriot here so
yeah with white you very rarely see
isopenko lose these days
yeah a big big result and probably
actually on fire so far in this
tournament
and there we go one of the moves you
mentioned there
this pawn is gonna cost white a night
at least
it's probably just going to become a
queen as well so
okay not much left to do white can just
take that pawn but then the black knight
would easily be in time to stop the
remaining white central pawn and is
there any hope for the white king
somehow getting in front of the past
pawns
um you could try but okay white's trying
to bring the knight back to stop this
pawn but after this night check
black is simply going to push the other
pawn now yep and
he's gonna play with two pawns he can
easily sacrifice the knight and yeah
he's done that
and he's
pushed his corner pawn one square
forward i mean it's unstoppable yeah the
white knight can stop one of those two
pawns but not both of them and yeah this
one is game over any moment now black's
going to make a new queen and essepenko
has he resigned
yes yes he's given up wow
so janupomnyachi the winner of this
prestigious all-russian encounter
between the rising star and